so this question
is from uh revue if i'm pronouncing that
correctly
rivulet review let okay then
is language the substance of ideas or
merely the communicative apparatus
in other words can a thought or idea
exist in the brain without it being
capable of verbal articulation can
thought or can a thought or idea be
perceived
slash recognized only if it has been
verbally articulated very similar to
one of the questions before that's
pretty much back to the
preceding point there are things that go
on on our mind
uh my reaction to the particular shade
of the color
red is that an idea
well for david hume it was an idea
can i express it in words no
so i i think we're in the domain of
terminology
you can call it an idea if you want you
can call it
a vivid impression if you want but can
we articulate it
loosely but not exactly i can't convey
to you
my exact impression when i look at the
color of the wall behind you
i can't convey it in words so do i have
an idea of what it is
it's a matter of how we want to use the
word idea
you go back to the way in which the word
idea developed in
modern philosophy and science
the term idea for someone like say
descartes
was just an entity in the
theory of mind a sentence could be an
idea a phrase could be an idea an
impression could be an idea
some it's a theoretical entity
within the framework of some theory of
mind it's kind of like particle in
physics
physicists can't really tell you in fact
there are big debates about what a
particle is
but whatever it is it's some entity
which has a certain place
within a theoretical framework an
explanatory theoretical framework